[Music]
we're all part of one community
[Music]
hi everyone i'm jessica nabango coming
to you from the national geographic
headquarters in washington d.c
for over 130 years nat geo has used its
groundbreaking storytelling to inspire
the explorer and everyone
including me in october 2019
i became the first black woman to visit
every country in the world
travel has helped me better understand
the world and my place in it
but when traveling isn't possible nat
geo helps us all
explore the furthest reaches of the
earth and beyond
tonight i am happy to serve as your
guide as we embark on a musical journey
that will take us from the woodlands of
norway to the coast of california
we have an incredible earth day eve
lineup ahead with
uplifting musical performances by some
of our favorite
planet-loving artists alongside shout
outs from beloved national geographic
explorers
the party continues afterwards on nat
geo's tick tock
all of this as we count down to earth
day 2021
in the world premiere of secrets of the
whales on disney plus
in a moment singer songwriter alt bloom
will tell you
how you can be part of share your spot
nat geo's earth day hashtag
challenge so kick back and get ready to
celebrate our shared love for the planet
we all call home
where is your favorite spot that spot
where our planet feels most like home
where you feel most alive most hopeful
most connected to our world and others
national geographic wants you to share
your favorite spot
using share your spot we may even share
it with our hundreds of millions of
followers
a growing movement of people who love
our planet as much as you do
join us and share your spot
hi i'm aurora and i i think it's
fantastic to be here
with you on national geographic earth
day eve
i i especially love being here because
the matter of nature and the earth is
such an important cause for me
it lies so so close to my heart
for me nature is definitely the biggest
source
of inspiration and it's the only player
i feel like i think
i can go where no one ever asks you of
anything
you you can just purely exist out here
which i
really really love this forest is a
forest that means a lot to me
i spent a lot of time here as a child
and
it's very nice to be back i feel very at
home
[Music]
just like the seed
i don't know where to go
through dirt and shadow i grew
i'm reaching light through
the struggle just like the seed
i'm chasing the water
i unravel myself
in slow motion
[Music]
you cannot eat money
[Music]
[Music]
you cannot eat money or no
[Music]
you cannot
suffocate me
so my tears can be red
i will water the ground where i stand
so the flowers can grow back
again cause just like the seed
everything wants to land
we are burning our fingers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you cannot eat money oh no
you cannot eat money or not
when the next tree has fallen and the
rivers are
poison you cannot eat money oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
feed me
[Music]
feed me
feed me truth and feed me
praise
here i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you cannot eat
[Applause]
[Music]
you cannot eat money at all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
what a great way to start the night
after this
i'll be grabbing my phone to check out
everyone's happy places posted with
hashtag
share your spots so get on it now i'm
standing in the historic hubbard hall
the original home of the non-profit
national geographic society
for over 130 years the society has been
investing in bold people and
transformative ideas
including the two people we're about to
hear from before that
here's more about how the national
geographic society drives impact by
identifying
and funding an international community
of explorers
if i was an explorer if i was an
explorer i would wake up put on my hijab
put on my beer i would take my tools
to investigate i put on my spacesuit
[Music]
then i'd shoot off into the stars
if i was an explorer i wouldn't care
about getting dirty
i would take my findings back to the lab
to build things create new things
be an explorer is all about
understanding this world
better to show the world a different way
of seeing to venture
into unchartered territory my name is
arthur juan
anarias morales dominique de emil correa
gonzalez
and this is life
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everyone i'm dr ray wynne grant i'm
a wildlife ecologist and a national
geographic
explorer thank you for joining me and
national geographic for this
earth day eve celebration i love earth
day i feel like i celebrate it every
single time i go out and do my work
but on april 22nd i always love to
connect with nature
whether it's a trail or a local park or
even going to the beach
connecting with nature on april 22nd is
my way of giving back
and saying thanks some work i've been
doing recently that i'm super proud of
it's aiming to protect female animals to
make sure that they have the healthy
thriving habitats they need in order to
give birth
females create the next generation of
wild animals for our planet
and their health means the health of the
world where is my spot
here's my spot
[Music]
hello everyone my name is lily galceria
and i'm a national giant explorer
here in san diego california and my
favorite place in the whole wide world
the slab this place is really important
to me it brings together people
and planet and place we've got the blue
sky and the beautiful golden sun
the big trees the green grass in this
concrete that allows all of my friends
and i to come here every weekend to be
able to practice break dancing
earth day is about connectivity
understanding that we're connected to
people and place and planet
and this space represents that to me and
its fullest degree
so i wanted to share it with you join me
in the nacho family
for a celebration on earth day 2021
[Music]
bye
ah
[Music]
wonderful to hear from ray and lillygall
i see that breakdancing
is there a cooler job title than
national geographic explorer
right now i'm super excited to be among
the first to step
foot in the national geographic museum's
brand new exhibition
once upon a climb stories from everest
opening later this year
the exhibit is the latest in national
geographic's long history of working on
mount everest
including awarding nearly 200 grants for
everest related projects
in addition to being the world's highest
mountain everest is also a massive water
tower
that supplies drinking water to over a
billion people
making its protection all the more
important
but now we travel from nepal to sweden
to link up with jose gonzalez
who will be performing his brand new
track visions off his forthcoming album
local valley then we'll catch a
performance from one of the greatest
artists in world music today the
legendary angelique quijo
hi i'm jose gonzalez
i'm happy to be here with you on this
earth day eve
i'm excited as a longtime fan of
national geographic
and as a fan of our planet
we're filming this at satur vester
school near my hometown gothenburg
on the west coast of sweden
since i was a kid we used to cycle to
the ocean to hang out with friends and
family
and i love it by the archipelago with
its granite rocks
oaks and pine trees just by the water
the last couple of years i've been
writing and recording close to nature
taking walks while listening to sketches
of my half-finished songs
i have to say the forests and water give
me perspective
and calm suddenly i can pause my
ruminating thoughts
and feel at ease
the song i'm going to play is called
visions it's a song for humanity in the
anthropocene
we are the apes that are starting to
understand the universe
and our place in it we are changing our
surroundings
at an exceedingly rapid pace so much
that we're becoming stewards of our
planet
whether we like it or not
so we need visions visions of the future
collective visions that are wise enough
to learn from our past and from the
present
envisioning a future where we all can
flourish
[Music]
[Music]
fish
trying to make sense of the now
trying to make sense of the past
to show us how
[Music]
[Music]
for all sentient beings
[Music]
fish
cycles of growth and decay
cascading chains of events
with no one to praise or play
[Music]
avoidable suffering and pain
we are patiently hitching away
toward unreachable utopias
fish arms
enslaved by the forces of nature
elevated by mindless replicators
challenged to stir our collected
destiny
visions look at the magic
of reality
while accepting with all honesty
[Music]
that we can't know for sure what's next
[Music]
now we can't know for sure what's next
but that we're in this
together
we are here together
we are here together
we are here together
oh we are here together
we are here together
hello everyone my name is angeliquijo
and i'm so happy to be with national
geographic
to celebrate the earth day evening
this song dignity is about our dignity
as human beings as we live on the earth
that is carrying us that have carried
us for generations and i think it's
about time that we pay attention more to
mother earth
my continent is the one that is really
feeling the the heat
and feeling the pain of this global
change
and i think that we that's the reason
why i wrote this song with yemi alade
and i'm trying to bring the young
generation of musicians to raise their
voice
to save our earth and all together we
can surely do this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i wanna hold on to you
dignity can hurt you or heal you
dignity i wanna hold on to you
when you die yesterday when the gunman
shoot man down no retweet
no surrender he can push you no far down
many times ago we're not asleep with a
frog
we come in peace not in pieces
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
africa
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
he is he broke up when you die
yesterday when the gunman shoot man down
no retreat no surrender he can push you
no fall down
many come man ago we're not
[Music]
of hope in humanity
the last frontier of our own sanity
spread your love to all equality
and plants the seeds of radical beauty
the wind will block the light will show
real beauty on a brand new
the wind will block the light will show
real beauty on a brand new day
it will clog on the brand new day a
clear wet on a brand new day
it will glow on a brand new day we can
talk
[Music]
stand with your head straight
walk with your head straight
with your head straight
[Music]
next up the berkshires an epic
performance from the incomparable yo-yo
ma awaits
he is also featured in the may issue of
national geographic magazine
now on newsstands but first we're
honored to share a special message
from the ever inspiring dr jane goodall
hello this is jane goodall and it's
earth day
so thank you for joining me on earth day
it's a day when we should be celebrating
the wonder of this
amazing planet on which we live it's our
only home and
we still have so much to discover but
the tragedy is that we've been
disrespecting nature
and this is causing climate change
it's causing the loss of species the
loss of biodiversities
so we're in the sixth great extinction
and so
today on earth day we need to reflect
on the harm that we've done and think
about ways in which we can work together
to heal that harm before it's too late
and you know
just as an aside it was our disrespect
of nature and animals
that caused this terrible pandemic
that's led to so much suffering around
the world
and you know we created conditions with
trafficking animals around the world
killing them eating them
wildlife markets factory farms
and all these things we create
conditions where a pathogen lycoveris
can jump from an animal to a person
and sometimes create a new disease as
was the case with
kovic 19. bad luck for us that was very
contagious
and just went racing around the world
and we'll get through that but then
we're faced with two real threats
climate change
and loss of biodiversity and
that also is caused by our disrespect
for
both of these by our disrespect for
nature
so as i say on this earth day let's
get together and start thinking of ways
in which we can
heal some of this harm what can you do
what can i do i think first of all
we can make lists of what we as
individuals can do
to save the planet and that's something
you can all do
sit down discuss it with your friends
your parents
and make a list but not just for earth
day
we should look at this list every single
day because that's what it's going to
take
to save the planet so the message really
is earth day
every day earth day for planet earth
this beautiful planet that nurtures us
this environment of which we are part
and on which we depend and we mustn't go
on destroying it
partly because it's beautiful in its own
right partly because it's destroying our
great grandchildren's future if we don't
start healing it
you know we're already using up some
natural resources faster than
nature can replenish them and as species
become extinct
so it i like to think of it as tearing
holes in this beautiful tapestry of life
and as more and more species become
extinct
so this tapestry becomes more and more
tattered
and a whole ecosystem can collapse
so think of what you can do
as an individual i try to think every
day of my ecological footprint
i try to turn off lights and not waste
water
and well in the pandemic i haven't been
able to
fly or i haven't even driven anywhere so
i think my footprint has been especially
light
i'm not eating meat and trying to keep
away from dairy
i've been pretty well vegan while i've
been at home
and sending out messages all over the
world on zooms and podcasts
so that so that we encourage more and
more people
to lead lives that are friendly towards
nature
and that's what you can do and
our roots and shoots program which is
for young people
from preschool university and everything
in between
and even some adults now these are
exactly the kind of things that they
and other youth programs with the same
mission are doing
so think about all of this on earth day
do your bit
and together we can save the planet
thank you goodbye
[Music]
i'm so happy to join you from the
grounds of tanglewood
these berkshire hills and western
massachusetts have been a spiritual home
for many a source of inspiration
for makers of music and poetry for
builders of homes and communities
for millennia look to the shores of the
lake
in the distance lake mackinac
mackinac the home of the mohicans the
indigenous people of this place
who live now in upper wisconsin and are
known as
the stockbridge muncie band of mohican
indians
are the people for whom the waters are
never still
they used to share music on the shores
of the lake and they still
cherish this land as hallowed ground
today by combining the human enterprise
of music
with the majesty of nature we continue a
sacred practice
through the ephemeral nature of music we
are reminded that we are but
temporary custodians of this land and it
is our duty to cultivate the land
and ourselves to find balance between
humans and nature
as this place's indigenous people teach
us
in order that our species can survive
and thrive
so with gratitude
here is this offering of music for our
earth day
celebration
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
such a moving performance from yoyoma
you can learn more about him and nat
geo's new book
spark coming out april 27th from
best-selling author claudia calp
and does it get any better than jane
coming up next we have a world premiere
video from my morning jacket
as well as an appearance by singer
songwriter valerie june
and stick around still coming up are
performances by willie nelson
maggie rogers and so much more
hi i'm jim james from my morning jacket
and we are so grateful to be here with
you
and national geographic on earth day eve
as we know now more than ever it's so
important for us all
to send as much love as we can to mother
earth
for her continued healing and protection
thank you are we undercover
trying to discover
how it came to be
[Music]
singing
[Music]
all i is to do
[Music]
[Music]
over here
[Music]
reaching out
between
is
i am
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
reaching out
[Music]
between
so
[Music]
hmm i'm lucy hawks i'm a marine
biologist and a national geographic
explorer
and i'm here in devon on the south coast
of england
i'm passionate about protecting the
earth around me because i study some of
the most amazing animals that we share
it with
i study animal migration and i use
tracking tags to follow the incredible
movements of my greater species
because of my work i've been able to
find out that birds can make
flights of more than a thousand miles at
a time without needing to stop to eat
to drink or to sleep or that sea turtles
in our oceans can stay underwater for
more than
seven hours at a time and currently
i'm studying a small angry white sea
bird called the arctic turn
these birds weigh about the same as a
bar of soap but they can make a journey
every year from the arctic to antarctica
and back again
clocking up enough distance over the
course of their life to make
six return trips to the moon and back
we're tracking them
using tiny little tracking tags like
this and i can't tell you what a
privilege it is as a scientist to be
allowed to hold this amazing bird in my
hand
to look at this tiny little creature
that sees the world at a planetary scale
and the more i study these animals the
more passionate i am about protecting
the earth around me
and around you too because every spring
and fall the skies above you and the
oceans around you are filled with
incredible migratory species no matter
where you live on earth
and i consider myself really lucky to
share the planet with these animals
so thank you for joining me and the
national geographic on this earth day
eve celebration
hello there i'm valerie june i recorded
my performance for national geographic
at prospect park and i recorded a song
called home inside it's a song to remind
all of us that earth is a school
and how we treat the earth and how we
respect each other
is super super important for the healing
of our planet
as i wrote in my book mother earth is
continuously trying to communicate with
us
the environment is in a state of
emergency we're facing a climate crisis
but miraculous things can happen when we
are living
mindfully the smallest steps to respect
the earth
could positively shift the planet faster
than we could
ever dream would be possible i do
believe that each citizen
of the planet has a responsibility
to respect the earth to treat it kind
and in doing so
love and respect each other enjoy the
[Music]
song
i know their easy peace for
me help me to grow
that i believe in see
a stream that falls who am i into
fun that old king
steals my chat ring
i
[Applause]
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what a cool video for my morning jacket
in a stellar performance by valerie june
also great to hear from lucy next up
we've got national geographic explorer
and photographer
ryan scary giving us a sneak peek at
secrets of the whales the epic four-part
series premiering on disney plus
on earth day hi i'm brian scary
national geographic photographer and
producer and thank you for joining me
and nat geo for this earth day eve
celebration
you know throughout all the years that
i've been exploring the world's oceans
i've seen so many beautiful things but i
often see some pretty bad things out
there too
still i remain hopeful because i know
the ocean has the ability to heal itself
if we simply protect it
i first learned about this while working
on a story in new zealand about
marine protected areas and saw
underwater ecosystems that had rebounded
and were thriving because of
conservation so the place that
makes me feel most hopeful about the
future of the planet is the poor knights
island in new zealand
because it was there that i first
learned what was possible
i think every day should be earth day
because i've seen time and time again
just how extraordinary our planet is i
remain
passionate about our planet because
whether you travel to the ends of the
earth or into your own backyard
discoveries can be made and while earth
day is always a special day
this year there's a special reason to
celebrate my three-year project about
wales
culminates with the earth day premiere
of the disney plus original series
secrets of the whales it's also the
subject of my new national geographic
book of the same name
as well as a cover story in the may
issue of national geographic magazine
i'm excited to share a clip from the
series with all of you and hope you'll
check it out on disney plus
starting at midnight
whales are the world's most intelligent
giants
but they're still a mystery
only now are we beginning to understand
their secrets
right there right there
three years of filming reveal
an extraordinary truth
[Music]
whales have culture
each family speaks a unique language
[Music]
they love deeply
play with joy
[Music]
and mourn their dead
whales are just like us
and one of the smartest of them all is
proving that these social bonds
are the secret to their success
what amazing footage don't forget the
disney plus world premiere of secrets of
the whales is just a few hours away
for now let's check out a fun
performance of i don't want to live on
mars by the one and only ziggy marley
before rostem serenades us with these
kids
we knew hi i'm ziggy marley and i'm
very happy to be here celebrating
earth day on this earth day eve with
national geographic
earth is my mother there is no other so
for me
so for all of you so coming together
and giving some love showing some
appreciation and highlighting
the um affection and the importance of
respecting the earth and treating the
earth as a partner in our life
i think it's very important and i'm very
happy to be a part of it
so um thank you for having me and
enjoy this one is called i don't want to
live on mars and i wrote especially
it's a song dedicated to love my earth
you know i don't wanna live
on mars i don't wanna drive space cars
i just wanna be with you and do the
things we do
don't wanna escape to the moon can't let
the world go boom
i just wanna be with you and do the
right things to you
you give me everything i need
you're my garden you're my breeze let me
get down
and thank you please hey let me lay here
for a while cause your beauty makes me
high
if you smile and i will smile
yeah and let them beg wanting claire
nothing can compare your love is the
blue sky
your love is a butterfly
i don't wanna live on mars i don't wanna
drive space cars
i just wanna be with you and do the
things we
do don't wanna escape to the moon
can't let the world go boom i just want
to be
with you and do the right things to you
oh good karma you're my queen precious
things my eyes have seen
sweetest place they'd ever been
you make me feel just like a king i'll
never leave you for that girl
oh my darling you're my world
hey that [ __ ] called winter can be mean
summer's like i've never seen if they
say i'm love
crazy love crazy
yeah cuz i don't wanna live on mars
i don't wanna drastic stars i just wanna
be with you
let's do the things we do don't wanna
escape to the moon even if the world
whoa i just wanna be with you
and do the right things to you
[Music]
can't take the heat turn down the fire
can't swim don't damp the water
believe what you want this is my right
of you
[Music]
i'm gonna be true i got to get true to
you
cause i don't wanna live on mars yeah i
don't wanna drive space cars
i just wanna be with you and do the
things we do
don't wanna escape to the moon i can't
let the world go boom
i just wanna be with you i'll do the
right things to you
i don't wanna live on mars i don't wanna
drive space cars
i just wanna be with you let's do the
things we do
don't wanna escape to the moon you'll
even lift the
no no no i just wanna be with you
i'll do the right things to you cause i
don't wanna live on mars
love your mother earth blessed mother
day
hey what's up this is rossum it's so
nice to be here
with you all and with national
geographic on earth day
the song i'm going to play for you is
called these kids we knew
i wrote it while i had coveted 19.
the problems that we have in
our world are interrelated the
environment is something that we have to
all take care of
and these interrelated problems
can't be solved unless we solve all of
them
and it can't happen unless we do it all
together
um that's really how i feel about it and
hopefully some of that
philosophy made it into the song thank
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but the skies won't take
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those were truly wonderful performances
from ziggy and rostam
earlier we heard from jane goodall who
once said only if we understand what we
care
only if we care will we help only if we
help
shall all be saved that mindset has been
at the core of nat geo's purpose-driven
storytelling
and now they're taking that one step
further through the creation of planet
possible
national geographic's new platform to
inform
inspire and empower consumers to live
more lightly on the planet
here's more about this exciting new
program and then
we'll pay a visit to willie nelson's
backyard for a performance of
laws of nature
hurry the mountains
are calling
[Music]
diving in the lakes in
the ocean
just follow the rivers
and forests around you
the wild
[Music]
a feeling that can't be
erased
impossible's possible together
hi national geographic i'm willie nelson
and this is my song
walls of nature
[Laughter]
[Music]
i get my energy from the sun
and i'm not the only one
and i feel better when i'm done
i get my energy from the sun
i get my oxygen from the air
plenty for me and plenty to spare
and i can find it anywhere
i get my oxygen from here
[Music]
[Applause]
and i plant my seeds in a howling gale
the walls of nature still prevail
look at them seeds and look at me
the apple didn't fall far from the tree
[Music]
i get my water from the rain
and if it don't rain i'll die
[Music]
stormy weather saves my life
sometimes i laugh and i wonder why
stormy weather saves my life
sometimes i laugh and wonder
[Music]
we're getting closer and closer to the
world premiere of secrets of the whales
on disney plus
one of the biggest threats to marine
life is single-use plastics
so here i am in a dress made from 79
recycled plastic bottles isn't it the
perfect earth day eve outfit
and now we'll close out the program with
maggie rogers who will be delivering a
golden hour performance of
love you for a long time before we go
don't forget to share photos and videos
of your happy places
using share your spot and come over to
nat geo's tick tock next
for a very special after party thank you
so much for joining us
we hope you feel excited and inspired by
everything you've seen
and heard today happy earth day from
national geographic
hey i'm maggie rogers here with national
geographic on earth day eve
we are in beautiful tapanga canyon in
los angeles california
which i love for its wildness and for
its history of music
i am joined tonight by sam gandel and
sam wilks
two of my favorite musicians to play
love you for a long time
came in like a vision from the old waste
wind
like a bright new dream that i was
stepping in
saw your face and i knew it was a sign
and i still think about that moment
you know that i could never make this up
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm gonna love you for a long time
i'm gonna love you forever
oh i never knew it yeah you took me by
surprise while i was getting lost
so many things that i still wanna say
and if devotion
morning is you pick me up
oh the world is quiet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
can go
if i feel it in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
for a long
a long time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the voice is asking
for change
[Music]
and foreign way
i believe the impossible is possible
together
and we're gonna see
[Music]
the impossible is possible together
lakes in the oceans
float like the stars up
in space
[Music]
a feeling that can't be
i believe